[Music]
hello and welcome to Nakamura's and Game
Fiesta where things get a little Loco
this is insane in the endgame so let's
get into the first game which was a
clutch win by Nakamura against Carlson
talking about clutch he's been pretty
clutch whenever you've seen him play and
what is kind of astounding is that
whenever he was down a match point a
half a point he always bounced back and
right now we're going to see how he has
done that so looking at this position
you would claim that this is a middle
game and you wouldn't be wrong at all
however I would say this is more like a
middle game and game hybrid some people
say if you see Queens on the board
it cannot be an end game that's not true
by the way but if and once the Queens
are removed they consider it an end game
however in this case there won't be any
decisive meaning attacks or not yet or
highly unlikely and because of these
structures and a c6 pawn defect in the
position white will have structural
hopes and hopes to win an endgame so
this is kind of a middle game where you
will be at the end shifting towards the
endgame or the thing that we call an
endgame so in this position I am going
to ask you what would you play here
first off it is very important to point
out that white has a healthy space
advantage black is fairly cramped this
Knight is boxed in by those pawns on f4
d4 and the pawn on c5 but because of the
close nature of it all it's very hard
get close to Colin's position so here I
ask you dear viewer to give me an idea
what would you play here
just notice that the big target will be
on c6 and if you keep that in mind that
plan that Nakamura came up with will be
fairly easy to find
so I see rook takes b8 suggested Knight
takes v8 okay exactly what was played by
nakamura but now we have to find a good
old plan just to undermine that c6 font
now remember this is a very important
game between Nakamura and Carlsen
Clauson won the previous English opening
game and if Nakamura doesn't succeed in
winning this one he will have little to
no chances of bouncing back put the
knight on e5
he put a knight on e5 there would be
bishop takes e5 f e and after 97 there
is limited chances for you to break
through however as an idea and as a
threat Knight e5 is an option
so the big move was a night c1 let's try
to find out what is this move trying to
achieve it is definitely not going to be
three but it actually can go to through
a two to be four or d3 to be four in
fact d3 is a bit more useful because not
only does it threaten to go to before
and put pressure on the c6 spawn but it
also threatens this idea that you guys
already had suggested this Knight d5
move which would pressure the c6 from
their ninety seven ninety three and
Nakamura's Knights are closing in
inching ever closer to that c6
square one interesting tidbit about this
match and in general about Nakamura's
clutchless in these events is he always
held a knight in all of these matches
knowing that in reppin slash blitz games
it is very useful and is a tricky piece
to use in b5 a nice little move by
Carlsen stopping the screen B I mean
stopping this 90 b4 idea so this was a
splendid maneuver by Nakamura however it
stopped by cousin so we're back on
square one
how should we continue here if our
opponent objects to our knight being
positioned on b4 should be concede
should we concede
that is sort of a yes and no question
and I know some of you are not that
familiar with the chest as a source of
communication but whenever now come
we're up late night see 193 he said hey
I want to have this be for square and
calls Anne would respond and say yo I'm
not giving that to you you've got to
fight for it will be fight for it or not
will be concede and say ok ok man you've
got that square see Queen e2 suggested
Queen c3 was a bit a little bit more
circumspect than the other g4 that is
interesting it does gain some space
however you do weaken your King a little
bit if you play g4 also this pawn might
become a source of trouble in the future
might be for anyway well if you want to
play Knight b4 you have to prepare it
because right now it would be taken by
the lady
so Queen c3 exactly so nakamora insists
after this slight little maneuver he is
planting that pony on before and
pressing against that c6 pawn and here
actually comes a very very dubious move
by Magnus Carlsen not that it is
actually bad but it limits calls ins
chances of holding the position so he
could still survive after this move
however he will have to go through a
narrow path
so seeing that night b4 is coming
pressure on c6 and maybe 95 in the
future he played h5 which I don't think
is such a great move but I do want to
ask you dear viewers why do you think
this move is a little bit dubious let's
say compared to age 6 what is the
difference between these two moves what
could be the downside of playing h5 in
this position now mind you it is still
logical Carlsen is trying to take away
the g4 square however it does have a bit
of a flaw and a drawback
so there is an important square that
gets weakened as sigh saying the g5
square can become very very important
later on so that will be a big a problem
there it's not that he can't play Knight
g5 right now hope Knight g5 because
black can just take it and in case of a
clean ending this would be definitely be
a draw because the Queen would enter
through e2 and the perpetual would be
unavoidable however in the long term
once this Bishop is gone we can use this
Square fry night and then f7 Square can
become a potential target but seeing
that you've got to activate all of your
pieces making sure that this Knight g5
jump will be fairly useful there so your
nakamura plays Queen a3 hinting at Queen
a check and also putting pressure on the
c6 pawn king g7 a grandmaster lee move
just stepping out of checks which could
potentially win the c6 font now knowing
that Knight g5 will be our future plan
knowing that this is our future plan
which night would you choose to put on
e5
again if you go Knight g5 I just take
you in fact this pawn is hanging once
you move the Queen even this can become
a problem
however if black wants to be safe can
just take take maybe go queen b7 and
black is likely just to hold the game
comfortably so King g7 let's figure it
out which Knight would you put on e5
open the H file well dead could be
possible in fact going to age 3G for my
to be a plan but as mentioned earlier
your king safety matters and that Queen
still on the board
dad can become problematic because the
Queen can infiltrate the position let's
say here queen bee one actually queen
bee one might be a little dangerous but
eventually once you break through
I might invade get behind you and attack
the d4 ng four pawns and then black will
have enough counter chances over there
the denied yes
so in fact an ID e5 was played point
being whenever there's any exchanges
there black is going to suffer so calls
and naturally took where the bishop why
would the bishop you might ask well for
the following reason if you take here Fe
you've got to go back one problem is
that this Bishop has no real targets and
no real scope also there's a big juicy
pawn weakness on c6 which can become a
big target
once this Knight goes there and there is
no natural defenders you've got to bring
on your king to d7 to defend and that
can get very dicey over there so instead
he took on e5 f takes e5 and now the
plan becomes a reality this night is
going to go to g5 but can that Knight
win the game by in itself not really how
can we help out this Pony in the attack
what do we need to do so we can mount a
big pressure on this juicy f7 square
so now g5 is the move but how should we
follow up after 9 g5
so let's make the moves Queeny 295 you
already have some pressure on f7 however
that night alone will not win you the
game and h4 would stabilize this course
on g5 but it doesn't really help with
the attack
indeed Queen a7 is the way to go and
it's legendary and it's well known that
the Queen and Knight works well together
now even though cousin's position is not
yet losing not even near losing it can
get very dangerous
so if black plays h4 there is a
surprising solution here for white this
can get a little bit dicey because our
King is getting some heat after h3 and
Queenie four checks so we might want to
be solid and go for something that be
all looking forward to as we're watching
and insane in the endgame
so I could be react against h4
if you go Queen a7 you run into this
beautiful old trick of h3 takes and
Queenie for check and you have to kind
of fend off these tricky positions with
white however after Queen f3 you get
into an endgame which is very very
pleasant for white in fact here is the
critical movement where you can and
should decide which one to take with get
your endgame knowledge is out and decide
whether F takes is the best or H takes
why not age takes here well if you take
there I can check you and then indeed
that d4 pawn will become a target if
that happens checks here I take on the
floor and the whole construction for
white is collapsing no longer do you
have threats on f7 because if you go
here I have Knight takes e5 defending
the f7 pawn and hitting the lady so
let's go back to this critical moment F
takes G 3 indeed is the correct move why
normally you want to take two words the
center so the better move B H takes g3
however in this specific case we are in
an endgame legitimately there are no
Queens on the board anymore
so you want to create a past form and in
fact this position is the near winning
for white already because after you
create a passer you will also have a
plan of walking all the way to that c6
pump and even though possibly this
Knight can try to stop you
let's say 98 trying to get to b5 however
after age five age six there is no way
of stopping bite from winning all these
pawns so let's say h5 takes takes black
waits age six and the spawn is starting
to run
you take it takes and after ninety eight
you lose the c6 spawn its and probably
the game as well so that is why it's
important to know the basics of end
games that whenever you reach an endgame
you want to create a passer it doesn't
really matter on which side of the board
as long as it a passed pawn and with
combining this pawn weakness on c6 a
potential target for the king and that
pawn will be gone with those two
weaknesses it is more likely to be lost
than hold by black but back to the game
therefore cause them place queen g4
pressing this pawn h4 just defending the
knight if Queen takes d4 then there is
queen a7 except seven standing and nine
takes e5 naturally would defend that
pawn however takes and it is fork town
you're just going to lose the lady and
that the game
so cringy 4h for 9f8 and at the moment
it seems kind of safe for Carlson
because after Queen a7 there is this
little defensive move of Queen f5 and
everything's well defended if you would
go pawn hunting there is a very nice
little defensive idea for Carlson which
would save the day for him what could be
that move
seemingly it's completely lost you're
just going to lose this pawn you still
have to defend the f7 pawn because
whenever this lady leaves you just get
checkmate in on that fate
let's get made it so therefore you've
got to find a skillful little move here
[ __ ] will save the day by the way
yes imbalances are important when you're
trying to win the game you're trying to
create balances when you're trying to
hold and calls in right now is trying to
hold
yep nine eight seven and that is an
important idea black is willing to part
with the C pawn which in long term would
be a loss for plaque however in this
specific case the Queen is just so far
away from the king that this is just
going to end up in a perpetual even if
you go here I keep checking you you
can't really hide and even if you try to
hide on H - I have ample time to play
Queenie to hit this f2 pawn and just per
pet after that so even if you go clean
these seven for example takes here check
and I'm just gonna keep repeating with
Queen f2 and the Queen f1 check
so in general Queen and games are more
likely to end up in a draw than not
they're four nine eight seven is very
important of an idea here seeing that
Nakamura came up with a different
concept so he's not seeking a queen end
game but a knight end game so let's
pause a little bit and try to find
Nakamura's next move which was in Queen
a7 of course
so it is a white to move
so if you go clean at 3:00 and suggested
I can't just capture you takes and just
go after six and in fact you suddenly
have some weaknesses on c5 I'm going to
show you why three five or even
ninety-seven
there'll be an e5 break and then
suddenly the c5 pawn will have no
support at all and once you get a pawn
weakness on c5 your hopes of winning the
endgame kind of dwindles so takes takes
you might actually still hold this
however because I can win that pawn this
is going to end in a draw so Queen f3
even though you do achieve the success
of having so-called night ending but
after f6 takes King takes f6
ninety-seven and e5 the position is
likely to be closer to the draw than
anything else so nakamora did something
similar but instead of clean f3 played
Queen d3 and there is a little bit of a
difference and the difference is I'm
still trying to trap your queen also I
want to exchange Queen's ball on on my
terms and after f3 the Queen will be
forced to have five and the structure
would change and who would that favor
obviously it would favor white because
the more pawn weaknesses and more your
pawn structure deforms the more likely
you get into trouble
so this f3 is the big threat
so Carlson played the good move Queen f5
Dean takes f5 and here comes the big
question how would you take on f5 you
can take with the e pawn or with the
Jeep on you've got only two options one
of them is good the other one not so
much
sometimes it's good enough to think
about chess principles should we take it
over into the center or far away from it
really want to take towards the center
and in fact ethics at five even though
logical was the decisive mistake and
after death there's no way back and
Nakamura is going to clinch it but after
G takes f five the game would have been
drawn probably calls and fears was that
this pawn on aged five could become a
target but in fact that is just a visual
problem because that's the night h3y
can't go now g6 this angle ending is
obviously drawn I walk to b7 you walk to
a5 but I'm just going to keep slaloming
back back and forth over there so here
here here and the slaloming will start
back and forth and back and forth and
there is no way through
so not f4 is obviously a draw that
wouldn't be the big question but GF f or
possibly he was connection not f4 what
we are more interested in is the move
King f3 and walking the king over wait
no f4 weights or you can go have six
Knight f3 you want to keep the position
intact
Nagi six and even though my king will
walk around there this night we'll get
to g4 and there's just enough counter
play date there to hold but let's go
back to the game he chose a takes at
five on the other hand this looks very
logical by the way he's trying to make
sure that there's only one weakness on
c6 however the big problem is now you
can't really go after six it's actually
losing as we shall see in this game you
can get three f6 also night II 6 is not
a great idea
you chat dear viewers can you tell me
why night II 6 is not ideal right here
so there was a question in the any games
you might want to take away from the
center in some cases isn't that right
yeah I mean mostly you either want to
create a passport as we seen in an
earlier example or just try to make sure
that you have enough counterplay
he takes f5 was more of a conservative
choice by carlson and that was just not
the correct choice here he should have
looked for a more counterplay
so let's try to solve this dilemma how
to refute the move that is 96
okay Knight takes c6 F takes c6 just
remember you've got to provide some
lines and thoughts how you win I've
never seen anyone react to you've got
mate in 25 and they resigned they never
do that for some reason you either come
up with the moves or they'll never
resign I tested but it never works
taking f4 I'm going to wait around
kingi five King g7 and f3 or even f4 you
can't wait too long if you go king f7 I
go King gate six
and you're losing all of your pawns and
if you go King h7 I go King up six and
gobble up your whole Queen side and just
Queen all of my pawns okay can you have
three f6 this was Magnussen's plan
however is it a little bit flawed
he takes King takes f6 and now we have
to come up with a plan with white
first off we have to realize there are
the targets that is obviously on c6 is
there any other potential targets in the
position
the g6 phone yes and this is one of
those things that are very annoying the
c6 spawn is a weakness and even though
this pawn is defended by the knight and
the King once they start moving around
trying to defend the other guy on c6
this will become an issue
so King III Nakamura goes on the long
pilgrimage towards the b6 square if that
happens probably the c6 upon false 97 so
he is trying that has caused them to get
the night to b5 if you go here here here
96 I stopped you and after here Knight
c7 and Knight b5 there will be some
counter play against the d4 pawn however
mrs. Nakamura's sly little idea and he's
going for this a juicy e5 square plays
Knight f3 so now no longer can you go to
be 8 or if you do I'll plant my knight
on e5 and you can never ever move with
you or not again and this actually truly
turns into a king's ending Kings and
pawn anything with this night stuck
there if you go here
I'll just go here here f3 and I just out
tempo you and windage e6 pawn game over
so you can't do that to play King e6 91
just maneuvering this night to d3 where
it can go to be for pastoring the c6
font or pastoring the g6 1/9 to be 893
King at 6 and now nakamura comes up with
a very bold solution but a good one can
you spot it
so we all know ii v square is the
all-important square in this position
and he went with this very bold move of
f4 saying I don't need your king side
I'm just going to go for this pilgrimage
and when there and once I stabilize this
position and there's outpost for my
knight
I'm just going to be chillin 95 and if
you go for the same game again you're
just going down because my king will
bolt to g5 and then that end game and if
you don't and if you don't take on e5
then again you're suffering if you go
back he says I don't really need to go
this King f4 King job g5 route you can't
just go King c3 King before king b6 and
with this Knight stabilized you will
you're just going to lose the g6 pump
I'm going to show you why you couldn't
do this without at 4 so 95 meaning can
get 6 if you go here here and if you
wouldn't go this way but the other
direction there is this a little bit of
a funky move f4 and after GF King f5
there is some counter play here for a
black and he can hope to mess around a
little bit therefore he played at 4 just
to nip in the bud all types of
compensation and counter play there's no
more effort Tricky's and after this he
is completely lost takes 95 in d7 and
the King is just walking over to b6 and
then this upon is just promoting
viii again this night is terrible
just stop defending that g6 pawn ID 394
just bothering the d5 pawn king b3 king
gave four takes all those those funds
can be 697 and before all of those pawns
collapse Carlson resigned so he didn't
wait for this 1979 takes g6 he resigned
at move 57 so this was a very clutch
when by Nakamura tying the match at that
moment and as you can see and you will
see in the next game that often times
night endings will save Nakamura in a
certain match so let's go lets me get
there show you this game between
Nakamura and Corona where it was exactly
the same situation Nakamura lost the
first game against Corona
however in this one evil bounced back
and actually it's crucial because if you
tied a match in the Magnus Invitational
you would get one point and with me
saying that he most of the time at least
drawn a match that meant a lot for
qualification
so this is the Nakamura Khurana game and
again not foreign to Nakamura he has to
win it yet again to equalize now we're
not yet in an endgame
however Nakamura chooses to go for it
and place queen a3 so seeing this
position what would be your first
reaction your gut reaction what would
you play here for the black
now from an objective perspective this
position is near even however just
because the computer would say this is
drawn zero zero zero it doesn't mean you
can't play these positions and that's
actually one of those things that
Nakamura did extremely well this whole
event it was just very clutch and posing
lots of lots of problems for his
opponents in these very very sneaky
low-end games so I see Queen c7
suggested rook c7 suggested well can you
not trade Queens you still have to trade
Queens unfortunately for you because if
you move their Queen away your rook is
in danger also that pawn on a7
so you've got to exchange you got to
decide how to
so I see rook c7 queen a3 would be a
first reaction so you guys are correct
karana should have taken on a
three-night takes a three saying that he
is going to have a D file as a form of
compensation now Korona played rook c7
which at first set looks logical he's
trying to fight for the C file however
this is a little flawed and after this
he will have to play pretty precisely to
be and stay in game just to stay in game
so Queen takes c5 rook takes e5 and the
next move is the one that puts the cosh
on karana can you find it because at the
moment this looks fairly pleasant for
black
you've got the D file you have some
pressure on the C file it seems tedious
and very Jewish however Nakamura's next
move is going to be an unpleasant
surprise for Caruana
before well after before I can just drop
back and try to double on the C file and
indeed the big move is 96 who said in
the end game you can't use tactics in
this case Hikaru is using the fact that
you can't take on d6 because it is a
back ranker checkmate you can't give up
everything but the game would still end
up in a loss for a black so after 96 you
do lose the control of the C file and
after that these pawns will become a
little bit weakened rook takes c1 rook
takes c1 and a g5 g5 a very classy move
by Fabiano
he is getting rid of this back rancor
threat and saying if you take on b7 I
have rook b8 and there's target on b2
and enough play for white
however enter the night ending rook c8
at rich site you'd say this is nothing
special
however that's not the truth those pawns
are far away from this King and can
often become a target
so rook takes c8 I take c8 immediately
hitting on the a pond a 696 b5 so so far
so good
I'm not claiming that by this better
here however playing this position with
black is a little bit more annoying than
playing it with white
so how can we come an inch closer to
those ponds on a six and B five
and that is the key for the whole
position otherwise you can't put
pressure
yep night b7 the night is trying to
undermine the a sex and b5 pawns and
here comes the big dilemma is the night
ending really like a pawn ending or a
King's pawn ending and the answer is
that the words of Annamayya Kazarian no
it's not and both Winnick is wrong the
night ending is not a King's pawn ending
you don't have the simple solutions like
you have in the pawn endings bring your
king in the king is an important piece
it is still an important piece however
the dynamic is still a little bit more
complex than that so having that in mind
how would you activate this King on g8
you still have to activate it
would you go King f8 or King g7
Cheston says King f8 King f8 was
actually played by Khurana which looks
logical at first sight and if you have
that principle in mind what Botvinnik
said that it is literally a pawn ending
it King f8 and King g7 then you are
inclined to play it like it is but it
ain't because in this specific position
King g7 would have been much better
why because you can actually come closer
to your pawns via King f6 and King e5
which is the most important part of this
position so if Knight c5 a 593 a 494 b4
knight c6 pressing this pawn and here
karana would had to find a very
important move here this one would have
been important if he finds this move he
is likely to hold the draw but he didn't
if you go b3 I would just capture that
pawn and go 94 you don't have enough
time to counter-attack the b2 pond
however in this position Corona has a
wonderful resource that he missed
if you go a three I can just go b3 and
this will be a potential target later on
in 95 indeed because if I plays efore
there is a beautiful beautiful move by
black so if you're wondering pause the
video for a little bit try to figure it
out because the next one is just going
to blow your mind it's just beautiful
you think in any games there are no
tactics well you're wrong
chess is partly about positional play
and small tactics even here there is
this magnificent sacrifice of Knight c3
and what makes this brilliant is after B
takes c3 there's b3 and there's no way
you can stop this beep on from promoting
a be a B you still might try but you
will fail because your knight is just
not in time to stop this beep on from
promoting and after Knight c3 if this
works magically corona would have
attacked two pawns at the same time and
after night before Knight takes e4 this
position would be around even as the
King is just coming in quick holding the
position
so the other choice for Nakamura would
be to play b3 here if you go Knight c3
it's not as impressive as it is after e4
because now you would have night eggs
before a bab and you don't have enough
time to actually do there's 92 oh so
here what's the difference then night b4
a B a B maybe even this holds because if
B takes there's Knight takes a 2 and
this B pawn is running a maybe an ID for
and then this a pawn is faster okay so
probably because of this a pond you can
do this so that's why King g7 would have
been a little bit better
however even after King f8 he had
another chance to do it
a5 a4 b4 knight c6 a3 and here was his
last chance of getting a decent position
and after a 4 you have the same trick
Knight c3 after night before and I take
c4 and possibly should be able to hold
his game
a 3 B 3 and now with these pawns fixed
and with Knight d5 Knight c3 not ever
working because Knight d5 f 3 which is a
break big move you never ever have this
move because I take on before and you're
just losing now he was forced to take on
e3 Knight takes before and this case it
is sort of like a pawn ending because
the past pawns
usually when compared to pawns that are
just closer to the king
91 trying to inch closer King F 1 but
why it is just in time to play king d2
and this is kind of the big difference
if the King was on g7 and King f6 King
d5 the king would have been close enough
to hold the draw
not in this case because this King is
just too far away from the action and
once this Kings this King that is
reaches d2 it'll be night C 2 and 9
takes 83 Knight c3 in d1 this king is
coming there and once you have no more
pressure on the a2 pond I will have
night c2 and Knight takes a three King G
7 King be two might be five Kings e3 so
let's stop here just for a second you
can see the difference between White's
position and blacks position the black
king is far away from the action while
nakamura species are ready to pounce on
this a3 pawn and help this beep on to a
lady b5 night c2 this e3 pawn is
struggling and once this King joins the
battle that be pawn is just going to
make a run for it
King b6 King c4 Knight d6 King c5 so
when the situation is not fluid anymore
I kind of
agreement vote Vinick in saying that
this is much like a pawn
King and pawn endgame but when the
situation was still fluid coming back to
this Knight c3 idea this is nothing like
a King and pawn ending in game King and
pawn endgame in this specific case you
wouldn't have these kind of tactics
which works in this position which would
lead to a drop coming back to this
important position but already has a
formidable advantage as this pawn is
likely to fall in the near future and
Corona is far far away from creating his
own past bones he's six King c4 king c5
and with this King not in front of this
one on c5 to be pawn as said before it's
gonna make a run for it h5 Knight takes
c3 g4 takes takes in night c2 and this
is another important little twist by
Nakamura he makes sure that he protects
these squares wherever these pawns would
try to promote and now the a pawn is
just running with the beep on and this
is just going to be game over
pretty soon now 593 stopping at 4:00 at
4:00 I can take take and I g4 and you
don't have enough counter play on the
King side 93-94 king c6 and in this
sense and game logic still works you
want to have the opposition and you also
want to restrict your opponent's king so
now kuranes King cannot enter and now
the beep on and a pod is just going to
make a run for it I have six a4 spawn is
going at four Knight f1
you can't really play efore because
there's gf and you don't have enough
pieces to help support the e pawn and
you can even go this direction III takes
takes a six and you can't even stop my a
pawn from promoting so f3 was played a
595 King c5 e for King B for just making
sure there are no funny business with e3
FL III now you could just take take and
yes you have this protected pond but I'm
going to dislodge the g4 pawn with h3
and with two connected platforms it's an
easy one for Nakamura so King D for King
these six King takes c4 King C five and
a six and there is no way you can stop
the pawn or if you do you're going to
lose the g4 and xf3 pawns and it's going
to be game over so what we learned from
these games are always keep your Knights
in and games because you never know you
might actually trick your opponent or I
play them because you know those knight
endgames way better than others
so thank you for thank you so much for
watching and I hope you enjoyed these
Knight end games I hope you have a good
day or night wherever you are
[Music]
[Applause]
you